[Music]
in viral marketing news all right
submitted by Joe Mallya 2020 oh yeah
really interesting people in that group
yeah yeah yeah you got a lot of [ __ ]
vagabonds I'm gonna use that word
Everett by the way back the bonds yeah
what's a vagabond a vagabond is a
[ __ ] I don't know a trash person like
a thief or something
we're like one of those like [ __ ]
gypsies let's get gypsy the first time
ever heard that word was an Elton John
song yeah what song again can you feel
[Laughter]
can we look up the word begum on Tommy
dope if Bill Collins did that thought a
gypsy a thief or trash trashy person my
parents once in a full collins
restaurant late or restaurant
you mean concert they got a rest one
it's like it she meant concert I
messaged my dad at the concert and I'm
like so how many other Asian people are
there he goes I'm the litter I'm
literally the only [ __ ] one I'm like
a [ __ ] font a function your dad went
to a concert cuz my mom's white oh this
my stepmoms white so in mind my dad like
she wanted to go so bad she's all about
it Michael Collins right I didn't
realize I knew his music until she made
me listen to him doo-doo-doo
Agathon the definition a per side look
what you did I need to know we need all
these words you don't know I know like
the general terminal on how to use it
but I don't know like the specific you
know [ __ ] in your face what's with the
nobody doubted you stupid I doubted
myself a definition a person who wanders
from place to place without a home or
job there's a gypsy burglar nomad wonder
if people ask you enough you start to
question what the [ __ ] am I wrong
yeah cuz if you ask me something really
quick
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
chasey makes that am I saying that right
nice nice Joel you don't know who Casey
nice that is yo man why youtuber are you
don't [ __ ] with a lot of youtubers I
[ __ ] with that gremlin dude that guy is
don't man I [ __ ] love Keith how did
you just roast them and calm it about
this thing what is it a gremlin oh [ __ ]
I meant goblin like that's more like
goblin better-looking
I don't associate myself with David I
love Casey nice dead dude I wish I was
him what is he not me he looks weird
it's like the most artistic vlogger out
there artist he's very skilled what does
he do in his champions laws are so
you're the one that [ __ ] next level
the vlogs it made everybody put B rows
and [ __ ] in there wrong
yeah I try to compete against this fool
like in my mind was doing my own vlogs
but I wanted to kill myself so I said I
shouldn't live like that but I wish I
was I don't look like him but I want to
be him okay and I want his money
yeah and his daughter might be cute it's
evening for us then before like oh no oh
he's oh and he shouldn't almost fall um
he's actually good really good
he sold the company CNN Wow the
millionaire yeah and its face it's like
a baseball mitt okay we're talking about
you're not handsome okay
listen tell you a little something all
right I tell you this right okay I will
challenge my face against his and I
rarely ever see how can you find you in
not my wallet though Casey and I said as
is upset with Burger King for a recent
marketing ploy yeah
Burger King I'll say this I'm on Casey
nice debt side but I love Burger King
unless you sponsored me then we have a
different conversation
I can't burning tacos are on me we got
tacos yeah like in a room of likes fast
food tacos like jack-in-the-box better
better then Jack away [ __ ] you is so
crunchy its own project crunchy you
don't even know it do you guys remember
when Berto cheated yoga the other day it
[ __ ] up her brain you guys remember
when Burger King had ribs no straight-up
ribs and beef rib I mean pork ribs yeah
on the bone
oh no it was like a limited time offer
it was so good damn now I remember that
Burger King
they had this marketing tactic they
still use the king I miss him yeah they
do actually I don't like I can't
remember last time I seen him because he
was like a creepy guy like that would
show up out of nowhere yeah he look like
a rapist is it like the toilet and
Marshalls will just straight roasting
men the whole time their marketing ploy
thing here that they did is they went
back and they started liking a whole
bunch of influencers tweets from ten
years ago okay so that's creepy so then
how did they scroll so [ __ ] down you
know right so then he tweeted this out
why is Burger King liking my eight-year
old tweets alright nothing ten years ago
sorry from 2010 is what I'm saying okay
yeah Burger King liked all of these and
then four cans of tweeting some things
from 2010 are worth revisiting like our
old - like your old tweets and funnel
cake fries get them now for limited
times that's [ __ ] funny tweet what
the [ __ ] is that about
yeah so that's the reason why they were
liking 2010 tweets from a whole bunch of
people okay yeah so in case you did not
like that so she uploaded a video that
said exploited by Burger King and he
talks about all of that and she had a
middle finger I thought it was so
family-friendly here that's why he
blurted oh you could do that yeah what
you do know you can pull all your [ __ ]
up so I can say all kinds of regional
epithets and just make it all beeps but
if you can kind of hear all the things
behind it no you said the beep and then
you could argue what you said it's like
listening here you friggin what'd you
say I said friend my god you know you
probably was all your spunk I just bleep
the front part of it no but people can't
tell baggage though anyway so in that
video it's like it could have been his
thumb yep how long will fear do does he
pull them off to use it a lot like this
look at this one because this is
uncomfortable you got to go in which one
looks like a Lego hand dude can you do
this make a fist and then go out yep
that's the real yeah make a fist and
then go out this is the way two year old
to do it did what if tyka at the age of
three comes up to and she just goes like
this each I'm putting it on [ __ ] you
need to know which finger I think I put
that in his mouth and I push the top of
his head and his jaw closed oh there you
go alright bring it back to KP mindset
here so in his video he says
influencers we leverage social media to
make money us influencers weird not
brain surgeons or rocket scientists were
people of average intelligence because
of that it's not nice to manipulate us
speak for yourself bro so he's like he
started comparing himself another
influence
two little mice going for the cheese in
the trap' and then then she started
calling out Burger King to give back to
charity he's like I already gave you the
value by blasting this tweet out maybe
you can come back to me with an idea of
how Burger King can do something to help
one of these greater organizations that
looks after kids who have needs and then
this company called that's pretty true
why is he so mad though I kind of missed
that point because they just used or he
feels used how um because he tweeted out
like why is Burger King liking my tweets
from but they're not just doing just him
right he's like going there going across
them but I'm talking about everyone else
okay like they were manipulated yeah
into tweeting out Burger King because
they they liked their tweets oh I mean
you better don't have to but they knew
how they tricked because they so it's
weird if Nike all of a sudden starts
like the way you said someone followed
you someone that you like right yeah
p.m. to Noir or whatever yeah yeah and
then you would not to even the interview
so then you were like you were like oh
snaps like you started sharing with us
like oh this guy that I follow whatever
yeah right yeah and it's we it's a weird
behavior like why but I would never go
back to him like hey Pat you tricked me
well because he didn't do anything bad
right but then if he was like oh just
want to let you know that we're
launching our whatever and now that
conversation is public and now all your
fans can see that because it's like
Twitter although using it for
advertisement but yeah I use them for
imagine if you got used for a brand deal
but you didn't get paid exactly how like
how it is how like this told you yeah
like you started liking all your stuff
yeah instead of a response like oh [ __ ]
like we just what we just wanted to like
build our thing or whatever instead of
that they go hey guys since I have your
attention
[ __ ] buy my [ __ ] yes got his fans so
basically it's like you use my fan base
I see you didn't even [ __ ] yeah I
thought they just went back in his
Twitter and just like something and then
that's it how's the hospital no they did
it to all they did it to get people to
talk about remember you talked about
this tweet so this was solidifying that
they used other people to get free
marketing because they were like [ __ ]
dumb because I didn't get tweeted are
like why don't you go back in my tweets
ten years ago because I would have
promoted four
I would have never complained well they
would have got me so [ __ ] good you
guys are so genius I would have never
complained I always kept talking back
and forth I mean like that's great David
we got some free better than that and
I'm like that's cool too but anyways yes
so then this company called Zoo they oh
so by the way Burger King followed
casein I said after the whole video
thing and then I was like oh snap and
then this blue was like hey Keith nice
that you asked and we delivered here's
the Twitter impression value now BK
knows how much they owe you for the
children hope it helps and it says like
total activity 18k impressions fifteen
point nine million reached 2.1 million
so impressions value is eighty-three
thousand two hundred oh dang yeah so
that's how much that tweet or like those
toys were worried yeah Wow but look at
this company - they're trying to [ __ ]
come up come up on that [ __ ] - at the
same time yeah that's that's the weird
part right is that that's what people
use social media for even influencers do
that [ __ ] so they try to grab the
attention of other companies by baking
brand deals all the time yeah so like
who's who you can't everyone's trying to
jump on everybody jump on something
right so it's weird for me because he's
[ __ ] on Burger King and he's
protecting all these youtubers and stuff
and these social but they do that thing
to get brand deals all the time so
they're actually using a tactic that
influencers using consistently yeah yeah
because the way the influencers do it is
they're using the product right and in
hopes of like saying hey I actually
stand behind this product hopefully I'll
get their attention by saying hey I'm
using your product they see my value now
it's mutually beneficial that's one way
that's one way but this is not that's
one way another way and I think the more
common way is a lot of influencers they
actually just follow a bunch of the
brands that they hope they like and they
constantly tweet at them all the time in
the hopes that to them that's one that's
the minority way actually the majority
way is they follow on Nike Adidas Reebok
whatever whatever everything that I'm
gonna use and then I constantly tag them
all the time and hopefully someone
reaches out to me but that's still
mutually beneficial the other things
like it's still they're both they're
both benefiting do you know I mean so
this the influencer already bought their
product and is promoting it already -
they
fanbase and they all put hashtag ad if
it's sponsored right but if it's not
like they'll just say hey I just got
these shoes try ASIC whatever and then
they'll tag ASIC oh you mean like the
beginner influencers or anyone for it
yeah are you even big people do that my
pal tag Lululemon that aren't have
nothing to do with just to build a
relationship hopes of working together
so that's what a lot of influencers do
but that's what I'm saying like people
tweet at us all the time with that type
of [ __ ] that want to be you know I'm
saying that's a normal tactic right so
they'll be like hey Baba I'm a huge fan
yours Thanks and they go oh by the way
check out my soundcloud United mean so
what I see it as I'm not defending this
or something like that I'm just saying
that this is not a new tactic people
have been doing this forever it's just
that this Burger King social media
influence is actually smaller than KC
nya it's a smaller company is coming
after somebody who's in a bigger space
so they're just using the tactic as
somebody else has been using for a long
time maybe maybe I mean but they can
also just be like well yeah [ __ ] that
that [ __ ] sucks here KC you but
really just like they can just be
genuinely wanting to help because people
are so surprised that a big-ass
corporation is doing this it's coming
yeah you have the money for it's a big
corporation right but for some reason
what I see it as is is KC nice that's on
my name is way bigger than Burger Kings
so we're still small fry going for big
fries yes so what ended up happening is
Burger King tweeted slow KC and I said
we're ready to meet your suggestions
slide into our dm's real quick what's
your number small they are trying to
work with him now to see how they can be
where the influence they're trying to
get his attention how can we get a brand
or what some people are saying like what
if they we're already working together
and theirs look like this well it's not
no Casey's getting a lot of like prey
hey that's not happy you don't say that
about KC nice dad all right
PR week us they tweeted out YouTube star
KC nice that add to Burger King and then
the his quote and then Casey said didn't
mean to cause such a fuss was just a
joke I'm not actually upset yeah I've
been pretty crazy a joke
no one is manipulating anyone just a
joke what does that mean but you made a
whole video about yeah doesn't sound
like just a joke that's what makes
people think that they were both work
and I've never seen him joke in any of
his videos since I didn't see the video
I don't know why did he say that yeah
I'm so confused I've never seen him
joking any of his videos so that means
what that could have been a marketing
ploy like yeah I feel like that he has a
sense of humor but I've never seen him
joke around why would you put such a
negative light on a brand of marketing
and then he's flipping it off in his
panel yeah listen man Casey I just
defended the [ __ ] out of you right now
bro I don't know what you're trying to
play this like look like we all got
played by Casey did I got played by
Casey Neistat
amber you know right now I'm defending
both sides this case a nice Thank You
Brad yells yeah oh that's grain did he
give it though pay for brand deals yeah
my girl I always have the question of
its range cowgirl I actually don't know
what to think now I'm confused who knows
because peach and I side is also a
marketing genius so like the virality
event right yeah yeah we don't know
anymore
he's done some crazy [ __ ] in the past
you know that is pretty unethical though
because he's always trying to talk about
ethics and what's right and what's wrong
and and you know how people should treat
influencers and things like that
so if he did end up using his audience
and manipulate them in this way that's
just another sign of that dough man I
think he's well that's why that tweets
kind of art because um in the very
beginning of his vlog or its exploited
by breaking it says this is not a
commercial that's very actually tell
people Casey nice that didn't it's not
if it's not a scam I just don't
understand the this is not a joke Oh
like this is just a joke God don't take
it serious when he did do do it very
seriously yeah I can meet a whole video
and I kind of don't understand the whole
thing actually I'm still kind of
confused on the beginning part of why so
upset still are you guys going against
no no I don't know why he's freaking out
over this and I like I mean people like
each other stuff all the time it's not
like they used his likeness in a Burger
King video then I'm like okay cool
I mean that seems like a stretch like
when he used when he's usually mad about
something it's because YouTube or like
there's some real there's a serious [ __ ]
that everyone's kind of pissed about in
this case I was like okay I could kind
of see
but it's also like a pretty extreme way
to respond to something that's lives at
you yeah I could literally be like oh
[ __ ] look at this
Burger King [ __ ] like my old tweet I
don't even have to [ __ ] retweet it or
do anything yeah yeah you can just dick
around about it on Twitter and not make
a whole video and I guarantee you like
he's showing everyone like hey Burger
King followed me right I guarantee you
McDonald's follows him del Taco fall I
bet you so many [ __ ] other brands
follows him so he is he is he like
showing everybody that like hey look at
all these other you know big brands that
are falling the whole follow thing was
after he posted the video oh yeah and
then I guess it was like so they could
DM each other mmm Casey nice that can do
no wrong mmm I don't know man this is
this looks fishy looks weird I just hope
it's like not bad
[Music]